- Give me some leg waves here.
Ground down.
Maybe a (smacking sound)
heel clap or something.
- Damn!
(laughter)
- There's definitely some nerves
- going on.
- [Will] Right here.
- I'm about to show the
entire internet my goodies.
- I've never taken it off
seductively for somebody.
- I only take my clothes
off to shower, so ...
- Well, not just to shower.
- What couples can get out of performing
a sexy and sensual striptease
dance for each other
is just a fun, bonding experience.
- I feel like there's nowhere to go but up
(laughs)
after this.
So, let's just, ya know,
hope for the best.
- [Amber] You guys look scared.
First, you're gonna start just walking
to your partner, like in
a very slow, sexy way.
- I'm coming for you.
- You're luring them in.
When you get in front of them,
you'll come down.
La, la, la.
Toss it on the floor.
You don't need clothes around here.
(laughing)
- I'm definitely not wearing
enough clothes, you guys.
- Try not to hump the air.
(laughter)
More so, caress the air, you know.
- Caress the air, Honey.
- You'll lift your right leg up
and take it down nice and slow.
Booty first.
Give them all the booty.
Roll up, head is last.
- C'mon baby, you know what to do.
- Roll up kinda into a child's pose, good.
Oh, you can like, whip it around.
- I need some hair, man.
- Want some of my hair?
- Yeah, can I have some of your hair?
- Take some of mine.
- This is the color I want.
(laughs)
- Whispering in their ear.
You should whisper something I like.
Put it around your partner's neck.
- Oh!
- Ooh.
- They're way ahead of us.
Get going.
(laughing)
- You guys are doing great.
- So you can kinda give a little wiggle.
- Do him next, do him next.
(laughter)
- I'm sorry, Mom.
- Legs are doing a body roll.
Lift yourself.
- I'm taking a break.
(laughter)
- I always say there's no
place like home in my head.
[All] There's no place like home.
- Finish strong, finish strong.
- This is exhausting.
- Oh my God, this is though.
- So dizzy.
(clapping)
- That's it.
- Good job.
- You are like a young swan.
(laughter)
I'm ready for you.
(sexy dance music)
- What you got for me?
- Ow!
- I'm hotter by the minute.
- My clothes just wanna come off.
- This is a reason to study yoga.
- It was great to see him.
With his booty a little bit more.
- I got all hot and flustered from that.
- Yes.
- I wish all of my exercise
could be sexed up like this.
- I just kinda saw that he
was responding to stuff.
- Everything felt
extremely natural for me.
I feel like this is a sort
of voyage of discovery.
- Channel that inner Beyonce.
- I have felt warm, maybe
a little fuzzy inside.
It wasn't clear ahead
of time that stripping
causes immense dizziness.
- Yeah, no place like home.
- No place like home, no place like home.
- I just had like, a checklist in my head
of everything that I needed to do.
- Look at that core.
(laughs)
(kissing sounds)
(clapping)
- Yay!
(oohs and laughter)
- I can't stand up just yet.
- It was great.
- Well ...
(laughing)
- I really kinda don't
know what came over me.
- Everything felt extremely natural.
- I didn't know I had certain muscles.
- Maybe I might break these
out every once in a while.
- Booty push up
is one of my favorite
things in the world now.
- Very sweaty.
- I am so hungry.
- I definitely think that
we should never break up though,
because once the internet sees this,
we will never be able to date again.
Gosh, we were made for each other.